how are you
i'm doing excellent i'm talking about a
great film with two actors i really
enjoy watching so this is a very tough
day this is going very well so far
oh so before i uh we get into the movie
i always like asking a curveball at the
beginning and i promise these are not
hard-hitting
if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why oh
that's very good stephen
um
um
i think i might pick
maybe either the accused or tyrannosaur
i would pick wow
what would you pick
um
we should have said this one
i really don't know
maybe this one
maybe not
yeah dakota doesn't know which but i
imagine it's that something in three
hours she'll go
and
tomorrow yeah clarence
sorry this i was trying to think of the
name of the angel in uh it's a wonderful
life three days ago
and then i suddenly went clarence
said dakota's going to do that about it
yeah i don't know i have trouble
answering that question
i always think i could do better
i've heard you say that before and uh uh
and i disagree with you
i think you do pretty good
thank you exactly i agree with you
yeah um
uh olivia this is an individual question
for you um do you miss playing pc doris
thatcher
um
yeah i mean she was you know like so
much fun she would dirty
um
yeah she was fun
nothing like a bit of girl on girl
yeah but it's also quite nice to lay
everyone to rest and move on and do
different things but that was that was a
highlight of of fun yeah
um for both of you one jumping into why
i get to talk to you um i think that
this script is just so fantastic in the
way that it deals with things that are
just not talked about these are like
normally private conversations you have
with people but never depicted on screen
i'm assuming this is what for both of
you drew you immediately to this project
absolutely
i mean that's basically what we've been
saying all day yeah you're absolutely
right
[Music]
[Laughter]
so it's always nice well i guess sort of
saying what we're thinking
like i didn't mean for that to happen um
matt this is maggie's obviously first
time behind the camera she's obviously a
very talented actor what was it actually
like collaborating with her because i i
heard that she would like whisper at you
and give you notes yes she
yeah she she
did whisper i think that just her method
of giving notes was not to expose her
direction
not to expose you in front of everyone
the whole crew it's such a private like
a precious experience to
to be an actor acting and i guess i
didn't realize that until now like
thinking about how that kind of
conversation to be
not overheard by everyone because then
you're not wondering like oh is you know
the there's like larry the boom operator
gonna think i didn't nail it you know oh
yeah i never thought about that before
but it makes you feel very like
protected and safe and like you are in a
little bubble and in a little world and
that what you're doing is sacred
whispers are sacred you know
that's yeah absolutely right
that's what she did and what was lovely
is so so she might give dakota something
and need something different and then
we're sort of watching
yeah yeah where it's nice to try and
find out what the other one is
what were you told yeah yeah yeah
um it was so enjoyable it was very
creative lovely experience
i actually never thought about that as
an actor hearing like a note in front of
all the people and then everyone
i never it never even occurred to me but
that's such a brilliant thing
just whispering
yeah yeah that's absolutely right i
think you have we must have become like
very callous to hearing like can you do
this more or that less could you look
sexier yeah
like in front of everybody and you're
just like yep okay yep like i'm a thing
you know that has to do it right and it
didn't feel like that was maggie
um i am fascinated by the way actors
prepare for doing like a big scene so
hypothetically for both of you you have
a really big emotional or dramatic scene
on a monday you know it's gonna be hard
can you sort of take me through
your process getting ready for that
monday like how early on are you
breaking down
that scene and thinking about it
uh
i think i probably i'm disappointing in
my answers to these sort of questions
because uh
i'll be learning my lines and that's
kind of it and uh
and then if the script is good enough
it's all there and
um
and if you're working opposite someone
you know who's giving you everything i
think preparing is
it's not my bag anyway
um i like it to be
on the day and
[Music]
my main preparation is making sure i
know my words
yeah
yeah i think same for me
just knowing the scene
word wise backwards and forwards so that
then
on the day you can just play and see
what happens but i guess i'm always like
when you are working on something it's
always a little bit in your mind
is it well you can't go out without
think like
like it's always a little bit in my in
my mind like oh
that scene will just pop into my mind at
some point of the day but i'm not just
like sitting down and have like a work
space
you know yeah
so i've got uh i wish i had like a
method but i don't know
i've got a job next week and i haven't
started learning the lines yet in the
back of my head i'm thinking oh [ __ ] i
should have started ending my lines but
that's
that's it really
i hope they see this
oh god
yeah i mean in months
months away
yeah um
my last question for you i put on
twitter that i was going to talk to the
two of you and i was uh i didn't know
this but i a lot of people wanted me to
ask about some tattoo that happened
between the two i think i mentioned this
once to someone and now everyone
it i'm telling you it was like the
question that flowed through so i guess
i'm asking you can you talk about this
tattoo
i i asked dakota to give me a tattoo and
she did
yes i did
i'll leave it i'll stop it right there
um
i gotta end the interview i'm just gonna
say again i really really you both did
such a great job with this and um
congrats on the movie thank you so much
thanks lovely talking to you